[Music]
finally walking out of president is
something that I'll never forget
it was June 22nd 2010 one day after my
birthday beautiful sunny dandy Trey and
I walked out of prison with a lot of
optimism despite being told by the
officers that I would probably be back
in six months and when I walked out I
thought that I was returning to a
society that would be a lot more
forgiving and a lot more open to me
getting a second chance if I was willing
to follow the rules of society so get
out look for a job you know prove that I
want to work volunteer in my community
you know figure out ways to add value
and sadly and unfortunately society is
not really forgiving and not really as
open to second chances as I thought they
would be and it's really sad in the
sense that 90% of people weren't
incarcerated will at some point return
home and we have a choice and how we
welcome men and women back to our
community I personally believe that
there's not a human being
that isn't without flaws that that
hasn't had a bad moment and nobody would
want to be held hostage to that moment
for the rest of their life once the
person has served their time that means
that they should come out with a clean
slate and an opportunity to start over
and if we want them to have a successful
transition it means we have to be
willing to give them a true second
chance and not keep bringing up the past
unless they're you know repeating that
behavior but in most cases most people
want to just get out move on with their
life find employment find a safe place
to live and be free since Wade the
fullness of life sadly the systems that
are currently in place are very anemic
and this is one of the reason we have
almost a 70% recidivism rate
because prisons are doing a horrible job
at preparing men and women it's real in
society and when you think about the
reality of somebody being gone for
decades the world has completely shifted
when I walked out of prison after
serving 19 years I walked into a very
different world the language was
different everything was about
technology and digital and online and
social media and so when you think about
walking out of somewhere 20 years and
just being dropped into that and then
told to move along with life without
being prepared it basically sets a
person up to return to prison because
they just can't cope with the reality of
the world as it exists and we don't have
the mental psychological services in
place to help people process the trauma
they just experience as they return to
society like the prison is a very
traumatic environment it's a very
volatile environment and so to take
somebody literally from prison and drop
them into the world as it exists now
without giving them the tools that they
need to cope is really just poor
management and poor processes that we
have to really kind of rethink and you
know the level of mental illness inside
prison isn't something people fact Iran
is that when men and women who have
mental illness get out back to society
they don't have much support and place
to help them manage whatever their
mental illness is and so oftentimes they
end up right back in prison and so the
mental illness component you know when I
was in solitary confinement probably the
most shocking thing to me was the
treatment the men who had mental illness
men who were incapable of defending
themselves against the onslaught of
police brutality the starvation rituals
the been denied access to psychologists
or psychiatrists like that was shocking
to me that we're allowing this to happen
in a country that's supposed to be the
leader of the free world yet we may
we are torturing people who are mentally
incapable of defending themselves and
you know you don't walk out of that
environment without suffering from that
trauma even when it's not directed
towards you but you've been exposed to
it
for extended periods of times and so
there are some prisons that are taking
steps toward doing stuff that is
meaningful that really prepares men and
women to return to society and I would
like to see more of those type of
programs that's really preparing people
for how the world works now as opposed
to how it worked you know 10 15 20 years
ago so my personal views on a systemic
component of my incarceration and even
prior to that are very very deep you
know I think about when I got shot I was
17 years old and when I was taken to the
hospital
I was basically processed through as if
I was a car and a car factory no one
stepped in and said you know how do you
feel even though you experienced this
deep deep trauma no one said hey here's
our outlet for you to manage your
emotions and a mental reaction to that
environment and so the systemic nature
of that is that young lives of black
inner-city kids have no value in our
society and the expectation that this is
going to happen to them over and over
and that it should happen has been
accepted as a norm and society when I
think about my incarceration you know at
one point I was taking college courses
and I was averaging a 4.0 and then under
the President and Clinton administration
they changed this everything around with
this crime bill he passed and it took
colleges out and it took trades on the
took counseling out and so basically in
essence it was preparing the young man
who I was incarcerated with to go right
back out with no resources no assets and
so we eventually become a liability
your society because we're just weren't
being prepared for life after the racial
dynamics of our prison system is no
secret you know the reality of police
brutality that we see occurring within
our communities at an alarming rate and
sadly the fact that there is no justice
on the other side of these actions
speaks volumes about the systemic issues
that contributed to a lot of my
experiences inside prison and a lot of
things I experienced once I got out of
prison you know not having access to
housing because I have a felony on my
record and apartments can legally
discriminate against you when you have a
felony having to check a box about my
past even though my past was 20 years
prior to me trying to get an employment
opportunity you know so systemically
there's so many different things that
occur within the scope of our criminal
justice system that is dysfunctional is
disproportionately geared toward
minorities and people who live either
right at or well below the poverty line
and those are things that we have to fix
systemically I just think there's so
much that needs to be done to correct
the Department of Corrections
[Music]